هل فقدت الثقة في الثمانية كحد أقصى
، هل ستلغي بقية
طلبك جيدًا ، وبصراحة ، فإن
ثقتنا هي الآن موضع تساؤل ولكننا
لم نصل إلى النقطة التي قررنا
فيها الإلغاء لأننا
سننتظر ونرى التصحيح الذي  يتم
العمل من خلال الإشارة وعلينا
إقناع خدمتنا وأعتقد أن
العالم بأسره يجب أن يقنع نفسه
قبل أن نعيد هذا المكان الجوي إلى الهواء ،
دعني أوضح أنك تقول
أن هذا جديد  بالقول إنه حتى
لو تدربوا على مبدأ مفاده أن
مكسيم ليس لديه القدرة على
القيام بمحاكاة M casts ، فهذا صحيح
تمامًا لأن ريتشارد صحيح تمامًا
لأننا اتخذنا محاكاة max
هي الأولى في إفريقيا وتم
تثبيتها في بنايتنا  التي
تكتب لي بعد ذلك على بعد حوالي 100 متر
من مكاني الآن ونقوم بتدريب الطيارين لدينا
بينما نتحدث عن كل من ng و Max حتى
لا يكون لمحاكاة max
التكوين لمحاكاة MCAS
لأن MCAS i  أصبح الآن أمرًا
جديدًا على الصناعة ، حيث لم نعرف
عنه إلا بعد حادث الأسد الجوي
حيث تم إصدار الإعلان بواسطة Jeff